ein historischer moment red stage us
medien verkünden vor eineinhalb stunden
der demokrat joe biden wird neuer
präsident der 46 der vereinigten staaten
seine anhänger feiern nach einer
tagelangen zitterpartie
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg mit guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem entscheidenden samstag sport gibt
es auch in der sendung nachher mit
kristin in aller kürze 14 tage des
wartens sind zu ende der sieger der us
präsidentenwahl steht fest nach
einschätzung von allen großen us
fernsehsendern hat joe biden die wahl
gewonnen und kann rechnerisch nicht mehr
von dolmetschern eingeholt werden
die entscheidung für joe biden und gegen
donald trump feld vor gut eineinhalb
stunden nach weiteren auszählungen wird
der so wichtige große swing state
pennsylvania blau heißt beiden holt sich
die 20 wahlmänner stimmen dort kommt
damit auf mehr als 270 und wird als
sieger ausgerufen
amerika hat gewählt und jetzt auch ein
ergebnis der demokrat joe biden wird der
46 präsident der vereinigten staaten und
aus washington und wilmington sind
unsere korrespondenten zugeschaltet
zunächst zur mrt wissen nach washington
immer wie sicher ist dieser sieg jetzt
der sieger ist eigentlich sehr sicher
dann ist es ja nicht nur alleine
pennsylvania sondern in mehreren anderen
bundesstaaten liegt joe biden so
deutlich vorne
dass es kaum noch möglich ist dass
umzudrehen pennsylvania alleine reicht
aus die amerikanischen medien haben sehr
lange gewartet weil sie 100 prozent
sicher sein wollten das was an stimmen
noch auszuzählen ist reicht nicht mehr
oben donald trump am ende in
pennsylvania noch zum sieger zu machen
und wer pennsylvania gewinnt wird
präsident donald trump bräuchte georgia
und pennsylvania insofern sieht alles
danach aus als würde der nächste der 46
präsident der usa
joe biden heißen johannes hano ist in
joe biden heimatstadt wilmington
delaware johannes wann wird sich joe
biden zeigen und was muss ich jetzt
leisten
also wir waren heute morgen frühstücken
als die nachricht kam da brach spontaner
jubel aus in dem lokale leute haben
gesagt jeder hier würde so kennen
erkennt mich jemand zum frühstück her
und man hat sofort gespürt dass amerika
sich ändert und schon hat sich dann mit
einer presseerklärung an die
öffentlichkeit gewandt er hat gesagt er
seit demütig er fühle sich geehrt von
dem vertrauen das in ihn und keinmal
harris gesteckt würde
er hat gesagt auch unter schwierigsten
bedingungen habe diese wahl
stattgefunden und das habe gezeigt dass
das herz der demokratie hier in den usa
schlagen würde aufgerufen zur
zusammenarbeit denn zusammen sei man
unschlagbar in amerika und er will heute
abend hier hinter mir auf der bühne
auftreten um circa 8 uhr heute abend
will er seine acceptance spiel schalten
will er die wahl hier an dem vielen dank
für den moment nach memmingen rund
washington
die entscheidung ist also gefallen der
77 jährige joe biden wird als präsident
ins weiße haus einziehen
über den tag der entscheidung berichtet
ines trams
[Musik]
nach langem warten und zum auszählen am
tag vier nach der wahl rufen die großen
sender einen sieger aus joe biden wird
der 46 präsident der vereinigten staaten
die bühne für joe biden siegesrede steht
schon parat auftreten wird er erst am
abend schriftlich nur reagiert der
bislang ich fühle mich geehrt und bin
demütig angesichts des vertrauens dass
die amerikaner in mich und in die
gewählte vizepräsident in harrys setzen
präsident trump war kurz zuvor zum
golfen gefahren schriftlich gibt er
bekannt er will den sieg seines
herausforderers nicht anerkennen die
einfache tatsache ist dass diese wahl
noch lange nicht vorbei ist beiden ist
nicht der sieger aller staaten
geschweige denn der staaten die
umstritten sind
am morgen hatte er noch getwittert ich
habe die wahl bei weitem gewonnen
ein tweet den twitter mit einer
korrekturphase vor allem die stimmen der
briefwähler wild rampen nicht gewertet
sehen
das tram team spricht von betrug ohne
beweise vorzulegen seine fans in
michigan reagieren auf den neu
ausgerufenen präsidenten beiden
zweigeteilt er ist noch lange nicht
unser präsident lady com verschwinde joe
biden der vier am ende gewinnt dann
nehme ich diesen hut ab und setzte einen
beiden hut auf in washington ziehen joe
biden fans fürs weiße haus um dort
gemeinsam zu feiern
wir sind so aufgeregt wir sind so
glücklich für die nächsten vier jahre so
erleichtert wir waren nicht sicher dass
es heute schon passiert wir hatten etwas
sorge dass sich das noch zieht alles
wird besser frieden glück ein land das
zusammen gebracht wird
das ende von vier jahren schon feiern
sie doch der weg zur neuen
präsidentschaft der wird kein leichter
sein
joe biden steht jetzt vor der gewaltigen
herausforderung das zerrissene land
wieder zu einen er muss versuchen auch
die etwa 70 millionen jump wähler mit
ins boot zu holen
in seinem auftritt in der vergangenen
nacht hat er damit schon begonnen mit
dem appell wir mögen gegner seien aber
keine feinde
christoph distel berichtet alle wissen
er wird am abend auftreten aber joe
biden wartet lange bis kurz vor 11 das
rennen noch offen da will er gar nicht
erst in den verdacht kommen
dies könne eine präsidiale siegesrede
zur primetime werden ein gutes bisschen
wird sie es dann doch ich werde genauso
hart arbeiten für die die gegen mich
gestimmt haben wie für die die für mich
waren das ist der job das nennt sich
sorgfaltspflicht sieben minuten spricht
beiden draußen auf einem parkplatz in
seiner stadt wilmington wird konkret
plant die zukunft für sich und das land
ich möchte dass die leute wissen wir
warten nicht um uns an die arbeit zu
machen wir haben schon angefangen
mindestens einem geht das alles zu
schnell noch präsident jump hatte seinen
konkurrenten schon gestern am frühen
abend per twitter gewarnt joe biden
sollte nicht zu unrecht das amt des
präsidenten für sich beanspruchen
das gleiche könnte ich auch machen
gerichtsverfahren beginnen gerade erst
doch beiden schlägt die pflöcke seiner
politik ein
corona wirtschaft rassismus klimawandel
darum wolle er sich als präsident
kümmern
und natürlich um das große amerikanische
thema wie kann sich ein so gespaltenes
land zusammenraufen
in einem bin ich sicher die große
mehrheit 150 millionen wähler will das
gift aus der politik raus haben bei
vielen werden wir nicht einer meinung
sein aber zumindest können wir uns doch
darauf einigen zivilen miteinander
umzugehen
dann sagt beiden noch schnell wieder zu
seinen anhängern zu sprechen und tritt
zum letzten mal ab als kandidat sein
nächster auftritt präsident in spe
genau in wenigen stunden wir gehen noch
mal nach washington zu reisen
donald trump hat klar gemacht er wird
diese wahl nicht akzeptieren will
rechtlich alles einschreiten was möglich
ist könnte das klappen
es ist zumindest der versuch das noch
herauszuzögern aber wir wissen von den
reaktionen von rechter in den
verschiedenen bundesstaaten in den
letzten tagen dass sie ganz klar sagen
wo sind die beweise bisher sind keine
beweise für wahlbetrug vorgelegt worden
auch behauptungen das sah man angeblich
keine wahlbeobachter in den wahllokalen
haben konnte sind zurückgewiesen eine
ein richter hat gesagt wo ist das
problem eigentlich und auch die
vertreter der entscheidenden
bundesstaaten pennsylvania und arizona
dort ist es eine republikanische
regierung sagen ganz klar es gab hier
keinen betrug das wahlergebnis ist
verlässlich also die chancen vor gericht
für den fonds sind sehr gering auch wenn
er sich weigert das jetzt anzuerkennen
gehören fröhliche hupkonzerte im
hintergrund in washington aber das land
ist extrem zerrissen
mit was rechnen sie in den nächsten
tagen wird es da zu ausschreitungen
kommen
ja es ist nicht auszuschliessen hier in
washington ist klar ist sehr
demokratisch geprägt deswegen wird hier
groß gefeiert auch vor dem weissen haus
da mussten wir gerade weg sonst hätten
wir kein signal mehr gehabt aber
tatsächlich im land ist man tief
gespalten
es gibt menschen die anhänger von donald
trump die bereit sind ihn auch notfalls
mit waffengewalt zu verteidigen und das
ist jetzt der punkt wo es auf die
demokratischen institutionen dieses
landes ankommt allen voran natürlich
auch die gerichte
die ihre unabhängigkeit beweisen müssen
aber auch die anführer der
republikanischen partei die den
präsidenten klar machen müssen dass er
der demokratie der republik nicht damit
dient wenn er jetzt weiter die stimmung
anheizt und öl ins feuer gießt
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
washington danke emma t wissen wir
kommen nach deutschland die kanzlerin
gratulierte joe biden und der neuen vize
präsidentin kamalla haares zum wahlsieg
per twitter schrieb merkel
unsere transatlantische freundschaft ist
unersetzlich wenn wir die großen
herausforderungen unserer
zeit bewältigen wollen und außenminister
maß twitterte wir wollen in unserer
zusammenarbeit investieren für einen
transatlantischen neuanfang einen new
deal und wir gehen direkt nach berlin zu
unserer hauptstadt korrespondent in
chuck und allah banerjee wie würden sie
die stimmung in berlin beschreiben ist
die erleichterung dort zu spüren wie
sind die reaktionen
also hier in berlin fallen jetzt die
ganze ganzen zurück haltungen die man
sich offensichtlich in den letzten tagen
auferlegt hatte das statement von angela
merkel haben wir gerade schon gehört
auch der bundespräsident hat vor wenigen
minuten schon gratuliert sowohl joe
biden hat es auch kanada harris und auch
noch einmal auf die deutsch atlantische
freundschaft verwiesen
und das ist ein wenig ungewöhnlich in
einer situation die ja noch nicht
vollständig geklärt ist wo es noch
widerspruch gibt von trump auch wenn wir
eben gehört haben dass seine chancen
sich damit durchzusetzen nicht besonders
groß sind
joe biden selbst hat sich auch noch
nicht geäußert er hätte man erwarten
können dass vielleicht die
bundesregierung so lange noch wartet
aber angela merkel und der
bundespräsident sind auch nicht alleine
mit ihren gratulationen der vizekanzler
olaf scholz hat sich auch geäußert hat
gratuliert alle drei kandidaten im
rennen um den cdu vorsitz haben
gratuliert auch markus söder hat
gratuliert also alle die momentan im
gespräch sind hier für höhere ämter und
im rennen möglicherweise sind haben sich
geäußert und man sieht da doch dass die
anspannung hier sehr groß war allen
gemein ist übrigens inhaltlich dass sie
die hoffnung äußern auf jetzt
verbesserte beziehungen mit dem neuen
präsidenten und es bleibt natürlich ein
kleines restrisiko solange noch nicht
klar ist ob donald trump hier klein
beigeben wird allerdings ist die
äußerung hier aus berlin von der
bundeskanzlerin und von herrn steinmeier
auch ein zeichen dafür dass nun der
druck auf donald trump wächst wer das
internationale anerkennung dieses
wahlergebnisses gibt wie das dann
ausgeht müssen wir sehen
vielen dank für diese informationen live
aus berlin und zum sieg joe biden bei
der us-präsidentenwahl nun einen
kommentar funktion als chefredakteur
peter frey joe biden hat es geschafft
mit 77 und mit einer botschaft der
beruhigung hat er die höchste zahl von
wählerinnen und wähler errungen
die es je in der us geschichte gab die
vereinigten staaten haben die chance auf
einen neuen anfang
der populismus hat eine entscheidende
niederlage erlitten
denn heute wurde donald trump selbst
gefeuert von seinem volk mehrheit ist
mehrheit ein schlechter verlierer bleibt
er trotzdem mit seinen juristischen
einsprüchen und den wutausbrüchen auf
twitter die seiner getreuen zu gewalt
auf der straße treiben
dabei ist seine show gelaufen
das muss die republikanische partei ihm
jetzt klar machen denn auch sie braucht
einen glaubwürdigen neuanfang der muss
mit einer klaren ansage an trump
beginnen das weiße haus zu verlassen
doch die frage bleibt was wird aus
seinen knapp 70 millionen unterlegenen
wlan auf sie muss joe biden jetzt zu
gehen um die nation wieder
zusammenzubringen innenpolitik wird das
hauptspielfeld des neuen präsidenten
sein
corona besiegen die wirtschaft wieder
aufbauen jobs sichern nur so kann beiden
eine verunsicherte teils radikalisierte
mittelschicht zurückgewinnen
auch seine außenpolitik muss zu diesem
ziel beitragen
in der handels- und klimapolitik sind
substanzielle annäherungen zu erwarten
zum beispiel die rückkehr zum pariser
klimaabkommen auch die bilaterale
atmosphäre wird schnell besser werden
aber das hat auch einen preis um den
neuen präsidenten innenpolitisch
beinfreiheit zu verschaffen muss
deutschland muss europa mehr in die
eigene tasche greifen in der
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
die zeiten in denen wir deutsche die
friedensdividende nach dem kalten krieg
in mehr wohlstand infrastruktur und
sozialleistungen investieren und den usa
den wesentlichen abschreckungs beitrag
über lassen konnten die sind vorbei
berlin hat beiden in sachen verteidigung
nicht so stehen lassen können die erst
den bewunderten obama und dann den
verachteten trump wir müssen uns den
wechsel in washington etwas kosten
lassen
auch in zeiten klammer kassen machen wir
uns nichts vor die partnerschaft mit
beiden amerika wird ihren preis fordern
wir sollten ihn zahlen auch um einen
neuen trend zu verhindern
peter frei kommentierte sieg vor beiden
tag der entscheidung in den usa dazu
sendet das zdf ein spezial direkt nach
uns und in der zdf- heute bleiben sie
überall und jederzeit auf dem laufenden
zum beispiel mit unserem live blog so
viel zu der entscheidung in den usa aber
auch das thema corona bleibt
brandaktuell in deutschland steigt die
zahl der neuinfektionen weiter an und
erreichte einen neuen höchststand
das robert koch institut meldet 23 1399
neue fälle innerhalb eines tages der
trend auch zu sehen im sieben tage
schnitt demnach haben sich täglich 19
1470 menschen mit dem virus infiziert
gestern lag der wert bei 18 1970 in
leipzig sind trotz der steigenden zahlen
etwa 20.000 menschen gegen die korona
maßnahmen auf die straße gegangen
sie folgten einem aufruf der stuttgarter
initiative quer denken viele teilnehmer
hielten sich nicht an die hygiene
auflagen also abstand halten und maske
tragen
die polizei löste die veranstaltung
daher am nachmittag auf viele
europäische länder haben ihre corona
maßnahmen nochmals drastisch verschärft
in polen stellen die schulen auf
fernunterricht um kultureinrichtungen
und geschäfte sind erneut geschlossen
einzige ausnahme lebensmittelläden und
apotheken das gilt auch in griechenland
seit heute morgen ist dort ein
dreiwöchiger lockdown für das ganze land
in kraft inklusive nächtliche
ausgangssperre
wer tagsüber einkaufen oder zum arzt
gehen will muss die behörden per sms
informieren und lettland ruft bereits
zum zweiten mal
gegen korona den notstand aus ab montag
wird das öffentliche leben zunächst für
vier wochen eingeschränkt und jetzt der
sport christin genau ich hab gleich was
schönes vom tennis deutschlands
topspieler alexander zverev bleibt in
der erfolgsspur
eine woche vor beginn der atp finales
steht er im endspiel beim masters in
paris durch einen zweisatz triumph über
den weltranglisten zweiten rafael nadal
aus spanien
dieser mann demonstriert stärke strahlt
selbstvertrauen aus 14 12 gegen den
weltranglistenzweiten rafael nadal zum 2
1 wäre vielen paris bärenstarke der
eigentliche favorit nadal hingegen mit
dem problem zu diesem zeitpunkt neun
asse bereits fürs wäre den ersten satz
gewinnt er nach 38 minuten mit 6 4 im
zweiten satz wirkt nadal genervt von
sich selbst wenn zverev schied mit 4 zu
2 davon
ein hart umkämpftes match wäre bei
aufschlag nadal im glück bereitet mit
diesem punkt das entscheidende break vor
zum 65 nach einer stunde 39 minuten
matchballs wäre es bezwingt nadal 6 4
und 7 5 und trifft morgen im finale auch
den russen mädchen und die french open
doppel gewinner kevin grafites andreas
mies sind von 23.30 an im aktuellen
sportstudio darin alles zum siebten
fußball bundesliga spieltag und
ausführlich natürlich zum topspiel
dortmund bayern die wissen dass leipzig
durch das 13 0 gegen freiburg zunächst
die tabellenführung übernommen hat in
augsburg gewinnt härter 13 0 und bruno
labbadia als trainer sein hundertstes
bundesligaspiel union berlin souverän 15
0 gegen bielefeld
der andere aufsteiger aus stuttgart 2 2
gegen frankfurt erster punktgewinn für
mainz 2 zu 2 im kellerduell gegen
schalke
der gipfel läuft gestern bremen köln
eins zu eins vorläufiger spitzenreiter
also rb leipzig union berlin vorerst
hoch auf vier hinter stuttgart und
bremen rutscht augsburg auf 9
in der unteren hälfte verbessert sich
herta erstmal auf 12 am tabellenende
bleibt das bisher sieglose trio köln
schalke und mainz das schlusslicht
verbucht den ersten punkt und noch zum
radsport vorjahresgewinner primus roger
slowenien steht erneut
vor dem gewinnen der spanien rundfahrt
vuelta ziemlich ausgepowert verteidigt
der auf der vorletzten etappe das rote
trikot und führt mit 24 sekunden
weiterhin die gesamtwertung an
den tagessieg sicherte sich der franzose
david guetta und morgen heißt es dann
noch ausrollen nach madrid das wetter
bringt wolken aber auch sonne die
details hat gleich osten terry christian
sievers erwartet sie später in einem
heute journals spezial zum sieg von joe
biden um 21 uhr 45 hier geht es direkt
weiter mit dem zdf spezial zur
entscheidung in den usa
wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
schönen abend und sind morgen wieder
daten auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schön kunde und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter das hier ist der satelliten 5
von heute und sie sehen hier im
nordosten vor allem dichte bewölkung das
war eigentlich hauptsächlich nebel der
dann im tagesverlauf allmählich nach
nordosten abgezogen ist aber schauen sie
im süden da war es auch ziemlich dicht
mit nebel und dort blieb es auch fast
den ganzen tag dicht ansonsten gab es
viel sonnenschein von einem blauen
himmel in der nacht bildet sich neuer
nebel vor allem nach norden hin
im süden hält sich der nebel weiterhin
in den östlichen landesteilen zeigen
sich die sterne und die temperaturen
sinken auf minus zwei grad hier noch
kälter ist es im südosten mit minus 4
grad und 8 grad mild ist es ganz im
westen deutschlands morgen im
tagesverlauf kommen neue wolken von
westen aufgezogen ja und im osten da
scheint verbreitet die sonne an der
donau bleibt es oft dichte und das bei
temperaturen bis 19 grad am niederrhein
und 5 grad bei nebel im südosten die
kommenden tage
am montag gibt es weiterhin im süden vor
allem nach osten hin südosten in ihr an
der donau nebel sonst sonnenschein bei 5
bis 19 grad dienstag ähnlich und
mittwoch liegen die werte bei 6 bis 14
grad bei vielen wolken ein schöner abend